[Music]
I could not have written ready player 1
if I had not grown up on a steady diet
of Steven Spielberg movies it would have
been a different story or I might not
have written it at all
his work is woven into the fabric of my
life
[Music]
everybody I think who dreams of making
movies dreams of getting to work with
him it's a dream come true
[Music]
when I read ready player one it was the
most amazing flash-forward and flashback
at the same time I was born in 2025 but
I wish I'd grown up in the 1980s my
Khalid a and moral like all my heroes
[Music]
I suddenly saw a future that earned his
client the writer of the book envisioned
it wasn't that far away from what I
think is going to happen someday I live
here in Columbus Ohio in 2045 Columbus
is the fastest-growing city on earth but
it sure doesn't seem like it when you
live in the stacks there's a dystopian
society and the fabric of our economy is
crumbling it's a good time to escape so
the virtual reality will be a super drug
they called our generation than missing
millions missing not because we went
anywhere there's nowhere left to go
nowhere except the Oasis
[Music]
I was very careful with Ernie
collaborating with me every step of the
way to be able to find the movie
narrative inside this dense forest of
Ernie's so found imagination
the Oasis being the ultimate toy box
with all the toys in the world and then
playing that with one of the greatest
filmmakers of all time it results in
just amazing action and such a fun
adventure
[Music]
ernest cline is such a visionary and i
has seen the future before any of us
possibly could even imagine it
[Music]
hey everybody so Steven Spielberg just
dropped a brand new ready player one
trailer this time narrating a little bit
about the creative process you probably
picked up on the fun that they were
having with the new footage that they
dropped so obviously new trailer new
footage but Steven Spielberg was talking
about Ernst Klein's mind as Wade was
walking in to inspect Halliday's
journals so you see like this giant mind
space that's organized like a library
meant to sort of a joke on Ernst Klein's
imagination as he was coming up with
ready player one they prefaced it with
that Steven Spielberg highlight reel
he actually said specifically Steven
Spielberg himself that there was a real
conversation they had about how much of
his movies that they would let into this
movie because obviously the whole book
is all about 80s nostalgia but Steven
Spielberg is such a huge part of that
that him working on the movie got to
this really meta place like wait a
minute
we're basically re mixing all of Steven
Spielberg's movies so they didn't want
it to feel like it was overpowering the
film so if it feels like they went
overboard on Spielberg they actually
held back quite a bit and you also have
to remember that because he's such a
powerful producer he gets an executive
producer title on a lot of films that he
doesn't actually direct himself so when
you think about it there's not as much
Steven Spielberg as you would think
because a lot of times on a lot of big
projects like the Transformers franchise
he's really a producer in name only he
doesn't have a lot to do with what's
going on with those movies but just
going through some of the other new
footage you get a better shot of some of
the slums like they paint a picture of a
future that Steven Spielberg says he
actually thinks has a legitimate chance
of happening which is kind of depressing
because it's so dystopian but you see
these drone shots you see them slowly
moving into the stacks and the funny
thing here I could make all kinds of
jokes because I went to college in Ohio
and this looks a little bit nicer than
the dorm I lived in we get some better
racing's more shots of the DeLorean it
feels very speed racer' if you remember
that movie with the colors toned down a
little bit like a more dystopian version
of Speed Racer
without a lot of the affectation of that
movie you know wonder how it'll be
received because a lot of people have
probably forgotten about that so if you
do have the chance to rewatch it before
you watch ready player one I recommend
checking it out and when you're thinking
about the most famous cards of all time
yeah you think DeLorean you think Batman
Beale which shows up in this scene here
but the mock pipe has got to be on that
list so I'll be interested to see how
much anime from the 80s makes it in here
too because even though they're hyping
up Iron Giant just because that's a
little more recent and a little more
Western you do see a Gundam in these big
fight scenes here so there is some anime
in here but I think for the most part
they tried to keep it as contemporary as
possible with exception for the really
really well-known pop culture from the
80s but speaking of which you walk into
the Holiday Journal building here look
at the background at diorama hallway
it's all arcade games so like you have
to access memories by playing the arcade
games but different memories are tied to
very specific video games just depending
on what the memory is we get a little
more of Artemis's character and then
more of this big scene in the Oasis the
thing about this though is this is
probably where you'll find the most
number of Easter eggs but they always
hide stuff in the background that's one
of the things that you have to watch for
when you've seen a movie three or four
times is you look in the background and
you'll find that a lot of the CG artists
will bake stuff in one of the best
examples of that is if you go back and
you watch the old Pixar films way before
Disney ever bought Lucasfilm they would
bake r2d2 into the background of certain
shots so you just have to imagine that
scenes like this or that on steroids but
then you have a lot of the easy ones too
like you have Iron Giant you have tracer
from overwatch you have chun-li from
Street Fighter you have the Gundam I
think so far some of the biggest changes
literally the biggest changes the people
have spotted are the iron giant swab for
what seems like Ultraman by the end of
the film in the fact that Wade and
artemis know each other much earlier in
the story like they actually find out
who each other are in the book it didn't
happen until later there were a lot of
critics after that first trailer came
out that said that they were originally
trying to do that to strengthen what
they thought was a weak link during the
book but I think that just depends on
how you feel about the book and if you
haven't read the book I would recommend
checking it out because it's actually
pretty badass or if you're a big fan of
audiobooks I think that will Wheaton
actually narrates it but it's not a
super long read it's not like Game of
Thrones long and Ernst Klein did reveal
that he was writing a sequel to the book
but he hasn't said a whole lot about it
he just revealed during a livestream
that yes I'm working on it I can't say a
whole lot about it I think part of the
idea with today's IP is that you know
this is reinvigorating interest in his
novel
like guilties it was already really
popular but movies that are popular
always make the source material that
much more popular so he capitalizes on
that by writing a new book and the ideas
they would develop that into a sequel to
this movie - depending on what the story
of the sequel is but just let me know
what do you think of this trailer and
what do you think about the idea of a
sequel book - ready player one what
would you actually want that to cover
big news is we might also get a han Solo
trailer next week it's just a rumor but
there will be other black panther and
infinity war stuff dropping real soon
so be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos while you wait for everything
click here to watch the last big ready
player one trailer and click here for a
brand new infinity war thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight